Salut ! Non ce n'est pas une référence à Taupe10, mais ça me fais bien rire  quand même !
Nous sommes en pleine semaine spéciale micro expressions.
N'oubliez pas que dans la description il y a une playlist qui vous renvoie vers l'intégralité de ces vidéos.
Hier nous avons parlé ensemble de la colère, et bien aujourd'hui on va parler de la surprise.
Qui est surement la forme d'étonnement la plus prononcée.
Générique !
[musique du générique]
Pour voir les réactions de l'étonnement, au lieu de vous mettre un schéma ou quoi que ce soit, j'ai mieux qu'un schéma...
J'ai Léonard !
-Yo !
Et tu as une particularité entre autre Léonard avec tout ce que tu fais sur la chaîne, c'est les vidéos réactions.
-Ouais, c'est ça.
Et ça j'aime bien puisque forcément pour les micro expressions ça nous intéresse, mais là on va regarder ton visage.
La surprise dure toujours moins d'une seconde.
"Mais... en fait c'est ce que tu nous as dit pour toutes les micro expressions..."
Dans le principe oui, mais la colère par exemple qu'on a vu hier, peut durer un petit peu plus longtemps.
Ça peut devenir même un état.
Mais la surprise par essence c'est une réaction.
Une réaction à un stimuli et ensuite le visage cède la place à une expression neutre ou alors à une autre émotion.
Racontes nous quelque chose qui t'a énormément étonné.
-Quand la chanteuse Louane m'a follow.
-Ha ! Mais c'est ouf ça !
-La première fois, oui ça m'avait...
Aussi quand DavidLafargePokémon m'a dit qu'il me connaissait.
Ça, ça m'a fait super bizarre...
Les signaux majeurs de la surprise sont donc les sourcils qui vont remonter plus ou moins légèrement.
-Ça, ça m'a fait super bizarre... [ralenti]
En fonction de l'intensité de la surprise "Oh !"
En faisant cette tête bizarre vous venez de voir le deuxième indicateur qui est la bouche qui s'ouvre, qui s'entrouvre légèrement, ou alors qui s'ouvre énormément.
Et bien sûr les yeux qui s'écarquillent.
Alors ne vous attendez pas à voir ça: "HO !"
Les yeux qui s'écarquillent comme ça au max.
C'est beaucoup plus léger que ça.
[ralenti]
Dans le livre d'Heckman donc je vous remets tous les jours de cette semaine, le lien dans la description,
il y a un commentaire très intéressant.
Si vous voyez une expression de surprise qui dure plus d'une seconde sur le visage de quelqu'un alors c'est que cette surprise là est simulée.
C'est fake.
Alors peu importe la raison d'ailleurs.
Ça peut être pour faire plaisir à l'autre face à un cadeau, ça peut être une exagération, peu importe pourquoi, en tout cas si elle dure plus d'une seconde ce n'est pas une réelle surprise.
Autre chose à savoir sur les micro expressions, c'est qu'elles sont toujours liées à des muscles particuliers, et on ne va pas tous les nommer ici.
Mais ça veut dire que si la personne en face de vous a eu une opération chirurgicale, une paralysie, ou du botox, ce qui est de plus en plus fréquent,
vous aurez beaucoup de mal à identifier les micro expressions parce que ça paralyse aussi le muscle.
Suivant le degré de botox c'est même impossible...
Pour vous entraîner à voir exactement ce que donne la surprise, vous pouvez vous amuser à passer pour un psychopathe.
Commencez déjà à bien regarder les éléments clés.
Donc les yeux, les sourcils, et la bouche.
Et puis à un moment donné, sans prévenir, sans...
AAAH !
Vous lui hurlez dessus simplement.
Vous verrez un recul, peut être même les bras qui bougent.
Ça c'est une protection de base.
Mais vous verrez aussi tous les signes de la surprise.
Et peut être de la peur, et ensuite de la colère !
Au cours de cette semaine je vous ai proposé de vous concentrer sur des points clés par rapport au visage et de les regarder du coin de l’œil.
Ainsi quand ils bougeront durant les un quart de seconde, vous y serez plus sensible.
Je le répète, avant d'analyser, il faut pouvoir détecter et c'est le but de cette série.
Alors pour continuer ce qu'on a entamé hier, concentrez vous donc sur la bouche, comme ça vous verrez les pincements de la colère ou si elle s'entrouvre, par la surprise.
Sur les narines, toujours pour la colère.
Sur les sourcils également; est-ce qu'ils se lèvent ou est-ce qu'ils froncent vers le bas et vers le nez pour la colère ?
Et les yeux d'un point de vue écarquillements.
On est toujours sur cet axe là, vous pouvez imaginer un petit rectangle, c'est plus facile à surveiller que le visage en entier.
Merci beaucoup à Léonard de s'être prêté au jeu pour cette vidéo.
Regardez les vidéos, sur les vidéos réactions en fait qu'à fait Léonard.
Et vous allez pouvoir voir les moments où il est vraiment surpris avec ce qu'on a vu là.
Et on va faire une vidéo ensemble sur la chaîne de Léonard, un autre truc sur des techniques de mentalisme.
Au moment où vous regardez cette vidéo, alors la vidéo est sortie sur la chaine de Léonard.
-Une fiche ici ou par ici...
-Grave ! Elle est là la fiche.
-Ok.
-Elle est juste ici la fiche.
Et n'oubliez pas de vous abonner ici ou ici au Mental Vlog.
C'est une vidéo par jour depuis le premier janvier.
Rendez vous demain à 17H !
Ciao
[musique du générique de fin]